اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في مخيم قلنديا جنوب مدينه رام الله وافاد
مركز قلنديا الاعلامي ان قوات الاحتلال
استهدفت سمير عوني اصلا البالغ من العمر
41 عاما في صدره بعد محاولته الدفاع عن
نجله اثناء حمله اعتقالات اسرائيليه في
المخيم فجر اليوم وبحسب المركز منعت قوات
الاحتلال الاهالي من اسعافه
وتركته ينزف
كما استشهد الليل الماضيه الشاب سنه من
بلده الظاهريه برصاص مستوطن اسرائيلي قرب
مستوطنه حفات يهوده جنوب مدينه الخليل
جنوبي الضفه الغربيه بحجه طعنه بصوتنا في
المنطقه وعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان
مستوطنين وجنود الاحتلال تركوا سلام ينزف
ورفض السماح للطلاقم الطبيه الفلسطينيه
بانقاده وقال وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيليه ثمار انه اتصل بالمستوطن الذي
اطلق النار على الشاب امام وشكره على
تنفيذه عمليه جريئه حسب وصفه
انضم الينا من مخيم قلنديا شماليه القدس
مراسله الجزيره جواره البديري اهلا بك
جواره مزيد من المعلومات
والسياق الذي جاءت فيه هذه العمليه
الاسرائيليه وما نتج عنها
بما يحدث
الاجنابلس قوات خاصه اقتحمت الحي الغربي
من داخل البلده القديمه
وقامت باغلاق مداخل حاره الياسمينه تدور
اشتباكات مسلحه حسب وصفه بعض شهود العيان
الان وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه قالت واكدت
انه تم نقل الثلاثه اصابات من داخل ازقه
البلده القديمه الى مستشفيات همم المدينه
همم يبدو انه كل يوم قوات خاصه تقتحمم
مناطق عده تندلع همم تم اكتشافها من قبل
مقاومين تمدلع اشتباكات فيطلق الجيش
الاسرائيلي الرصاص الحي باتجاه المواطنين
الان قوات الاحتلال دفعت بتعزيزات الى
اكثر من محور في داخلي مدينتي نابلس ولكن
كالعاده يبدو ان العمليه قد تكون مجرد
تنفيذ حمله همم اعتقالات
قد تنتهي ولكن قد يتطور الامر لكن حتى هذه
الساعه لا يوجد سوى ان هناك ثلاثه اصابات
نقلت الى مستشفى رفيديا في نابلس اما هنا
في همم مخيم قلنديا للاجئين الفلسطينيين
شمالي القدس المحتله الادراك الشامل يعوم
كافه ارجاء المخيم
والمناطق المحيطه به
امام ماذا
لدينا صور من نابلس همم نستعرضها الان على
الشاشه
وايضا نذكر بما نقلته وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ثلاث اصابات برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحام البلده القديمه في
نابلس اذا هذه صور وصلت الان من نابلس
وكما اشارت وزاره الصحه الى الاصابات وهو
ما ذكرته انت في بدايه حديثك جباره
دخول القوات الله
خاصه الى داخل
تحديدا حاره الياسمينه في داخل البلده
القديمه يبدو ان المقاومين الفلسطينيين
اكتشفوا امرها فا اندلعت الاشتباكات ولكن
القوات الاحتلال تحاصر ايضا منزل في داخل
احدى الاصدقاء في داخل حاره الياسمين في
البلده القديمه وهناك تعزيزات عسكريه كما
ذكرنا في اكثر من محور من المحاور المؤديه
الى البلده القديمه وتحديده المنطقه
الغربيه
في نابلس سواء قام الاسعاف قبل دقائق كانت
قد اكدت ان قوات الاحتلال تمنع الطواقم
الطبيه من الدخول والوصول الى داخل البلده
القديمه لكنها الان نجحت وسمحت لها قوات
الاحتلال بالدخول الى هناك عوده الى هنا
ما يحدث في مخيم قلنديا اللاجئين عبد
السلام كنت قد ذكرت لك ان الان الاضراب
الشامل يعم انحاء المخيم ولكن هذه الطريقه
الان الرئيسي الذي يربط ما بين رام الله
والضفه الغربيه بالقدس بحاجه قلنديا
العسكري و نعم وهمم والحاجز الان كما نرى
همم يعني يبدو ان قوه الاحتلال تعرقل حركه
السيارات نحن في بدايه النهار وساعات
الدوام ولكن نحن نتحدث عن ثلاثه شهداء
سقطوا خلال 24 ساعه ليرتفع عدد الشهداء
منذ بدايه العام الى سبعه شهداء ما حدث
اليوم مع الشهيد سمير اصلا هو ما يدلل على
ان عمليات الاعتقال التي وصلت اليوم الى
معتقلا فلسطينيا هو ان قوات الاحتلال تدخل
الى داخل المنازل تداهم تعتدي على من في
الداخل وهذا ما حصل اليوم مع الشهيد عوني
الذي كان يحاول فقط ان ينقذ ابنه من
الاعتقال فقام جنود الاحتلال باطلاق
الرصاص المباشر الحي على صدره ومن قوى
الاحتلال الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول اليه
لانقاذ الان هو في مستشفى رام الله
الحكومي وسيم تشييع جثمانه بعد
ظهر هذا اليوم من المستشفى وصولا هنا الى
مخيم قلنديا للاجئين
مخيم قلنديا الشمالي القدس